- But let's talk "Grey's Anatomy".
Are there any surprises coming up?
- Yes, I mean, so if anybody
who watches the show knows...
Yeah (chuckles)
- [Kelly] Oh we had
some people freaking out
when I announced you earlier, so yeah.
- Oh really?
Well, this season they'll
know has been wild
because we had McDreamy
back like the first episode.
So we have, I've been telling everyone
and I think they just think
I'm promoting the show
to like watch live.
But watch live because we have so many
crazy, unexpected people coming back
that you wouldn't imagine
and I've gotta announce
that Sarah Drew who plays
April Kepner is coming back
for an episode too.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- We have a lot of surprises this season.
- [Kelly] That's kinda cool.